hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
we have some Avengers in game leaks
today we have less than 100 days almost
just three months until in-game comes
out and as we get closer and closer
expect more leaks to come out Marvel and
the Russo brothers are doing an
extremely well job at keeping everything
relating to Avengers in game s secret so
these leaks are really all that we have
before we dive into it I'm still doing a
new Infinity Gauntlet giveaway if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so today's leak seems
to be a first look at the Avengers
in-game Funko pop vinyl figures and
although there aren't any huge spoilers
here there are a few things to notice
Captain Marvel for the most part looks
pretty much the same her hair looks a
little bit different but that could just
be because of the way the toy is
designed Captain America for the most
part looks the same he does have his
helmet back on and it looks like he
could possibly be holding a shield he
doesn't have it in this image but the
way his arm is held there it looks like
he's holding one perhaps when the actual
figure comes out he will be holding a
shield but for these prototype images
he's not black widow looks the same for
the most part she does have her hair up
and pulled back like she does in a few
leaked photos that we got not too long
ago and like she has in some scenes of
The Avengers in-game trailer war machine
ant-man and nebula all looked the same
no changes here but if you look at
banner he's actually wearing a suit
banner never wears a suit but he is for
this figure and the very first promo
photo that we got for Avengers in game
we see the Hulk wearing a suit this is
just more evidence that an Avengers in
game we're going to see professor Hulk
banner never wears a suit The Hulk never
wears a suit for sure and now we have
photos of both of them wearing suits a
lot of evidence for professor hulk then
we take a look at feyo's Thanos has on
his armor and his double bladed sword in
his hand we were supposed to see the
sword in Avengers infinity war and we
were supposed to see
Thanos wearing a lot more of his armor
but we didn't but a lot of these leaked
photos that we have
and the promo photos that have came out
all show Thanos wearing his armor and
holding the sword this makes sense
because after the snap he was pretty
beat-up
so it would make sense for him to put
armor on and if he loses the Infinity
Gauntlet somehow or if it's damaged and
he can't use the stones it would make
sense for him to have a weapon and
that's why he has a sword and then we
have Tony who seems like he's wearing
his Iron Man suit but there's an
Avengers logo on it now perhaps this
could be a new suit there has been talk
of a Mark 85 being in Avengers in game
so perhaps he makes the mark 85 and
slaps an Avengers logo on it and then we
have Hawkeye who is still holding his
bow we know that he's going to become
Ronin in Avengers in game but it seems
like he may only become Ronin for a
short period of time and when he comes
back and regroups with the Avengers
he'll be Hawkeye again and then one of
the biggest differences that we have is
Thor his head is shaved it's done note
why he does this but it seems like at
some point in time in Avengers infinity
war he's going to feel the need to shave
his head perhaps we'll get a different
take on Thor in Avengers endgame we know
he probably feels a lot of guilt for not
going for the head plus he lost all of
his family and all of his people perhaps
we're going to see a more serious
version of Thor one that is determined
to make things right in Avengers endgame
so that's it for all these new Avengers
in game leaks let me know what you think
about these in the comments down below
and again don't forget to subscribe like
the video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so you can enter the giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
relating to Avengers endgame as always
thank you all so much for watching Wolf
Wolf
[Music]
you